hello everybody I hope they are good
first of all thank you very much for
watching yesterday's video and of course
for all the welcome messages it made my
day so I appreciate you all thank you
very much now this is the chart that we
drew in yesterday's video if you
remember we have or range highs or range
lows this gray line here is a a
potential support that we found that we
could test later in the future okay and
that would be a good entry possibly and
of course the imbalances in the chart
are this week to the upside okay this
quick here and of course these two
liquidity pools there is a large
liquidity pool to the upside and another
one to the downside so uh those are
essentially the the imbalances and the
key levels that we Mark in our chart now
if we look at what happened in the last
24 hours since yesterday's video is
pretty much nothing okay nothing
happened what is still in the a hours
time frame above the 50 EMA so that's a
good sign we of support and uh we were
talking about the idea that this could
be a good um entry or it could be a good
try to long with a very small size okay
towards the range highs now if we lose
the 8 hour 50ma and we start to close
candles below it that's going to tell us
the momentum is siting and then price
could go down okay that's what you would
open a short that's what I'm going to do
and I'm going to aim for this um these
three levels okay you have the this
potential support the Gray Line that's
what I would close most of my short and
of course I would open a long aiming for
that liquidity that we saw yesterday to
the upside through the order book and
the liquidation hit maps and also you
have this liquidity pull on this week
again okay but basically if we drop to
this Zone there are three levels where I
would like to open Longs okay and it's
this gray line here of course the range
lows and through this liquidity pool so
I would then just open one long I would
open several Longs I would basically
split that size into different or orders
because you know it might bounce away
from this gr line or it might drop away
lower to the range low and bounce from
there or even lower and feel like 100%
of this liquidity pool so um when you
are opening a position I always
recommend to build a position okay
that's what the market maker does the
market maker doesn't open a 100 million
dollar position in one go they splited
the DCA into the position okay so that's
how you um well that's at least how I
recommend you to trade okay always VCA
into a position if it's long or short
doesn't matter just try to DCA okay cuz
that's going to give you um two two good
things the first thing is that if if you
are right and price keeps going down
you're going to fill more orders and
that means that you're going to get a
better entry okay and the second thing
is that if it doesn't do that and it
just Bounce from the first or the second
level you are not going to miss out that
move because at least you want to be in
partially Okay so always try to this
into a position it's quite important to
me at this stage to to think what the
retail Trader is doing okay and it seems
very clear you go to Twitter and
everybody is is drawing the same chart
and it's basically this pant here okay
everybody let's go to the 4 hours time
frame it might be better everybody's
drawing the same pant everybody's
looking at the same thing and it's this
okay this pant don't know not how to
draw it I'm so sorry but basically
everybody's everybody's looking at this
thing it's a pen okay and what the ret
Traer is doing because this is what the
textbook say of conventional trading it
says you have a wave up you're in app
pant so you're going to have some
consolidation and this is meant to be
bullish consolidation for another move
of the same size okay so according to uh
the conventional trading books then this
should basically pump let me do it like
this okay so so I I think that's this is
how they do it this should basically go
to the 100% of the week okay that's what
the book say now we know that the market
maker likes to to to trap retail Traders
so um this is what happens in a lot of
times okay that's your I'm not going to
say it because I don't want to get uh um
a ban on YouTube or something um but
this is what happens a lot of times okay
that you have the move up consolidation
then you have a fake out this might even
reach to the range to the Range s okay
where there is some resistance and then
you have the drop okay so why not why
can't this happen Okay what I'm trying
to say with this is that if you see a
breakout from this pant from this
triangle don't get too excited okay
because this is something quite that
happens quite often probably as often as
breaking out okay I think that this uh
conventional trading system has around a
50% 55% of wi ratio and that's not much
so yes that might be right but this is
also a good a good chance that this
happen so um careful with that okay
don't trade based on these things uh at
least I don't just be careful but it's
good to to spot them and see what people
are talking about what the ril trader is
thinking because that's what the market
making is going to use to manipulate the
next move that's why I personally like
the idea of consolidation give me a fake
out to the range highs okay there is
also um if we split this liquidity pool
into two because it's two candles okay
we just put them there together there is
one liquidity pool here you can see the
Scandal okay so yes why not that's
perfectly matching with the range highs
fill the liquidity pool and then you'll
only have the other one for later on
okay then you can drop perhaps to the
range lows again into this Equity pool
retrace this liquidity pool here is what
I would be opening this here into my
Longs if this happen happened okay I
think this is the safest play if if we
drop here I'll be happy because that's
this is the move this long from here the
move that I'm more convinced um or I'm
more confident that that I that I'll win
okay so a drop to Wars this range lows
this liquidity pool I'll open some Longs
and aim to the range highs again to this
liquidity pool and of course that Weck
so that's pretty much everything that
I'm seeing guys uh just be very careful
with trading this penants because I mean
the winning race is not worth it okay
it's not worth to to trade based on this
of course um you can trade based on
conventional trading and you can win you
can be profitable of course you can
there are many traders that okay but
it's just not as easy because the
winning ratio is it's not there okay 50%
55% wi race is not enough for me at
least I need more I need 80 85% okay
then I'm happy with my trading system
okay I can trade with more confidence so
um this is a trade
the um I'm going to enter if I get the
entry with a small size and it's
basically taking a small entry from the
50 in the 8 hours time frame you can see
that it's been tested as support several
times 1 2 three times okay give me a
four time perhaps I enter here then aim
for the range size get out there if it
continues we'll see okay because then I
would like to see some consolidation
above R size I can re-enter towards that
week otherwise if we drop below the 50
minut the 8 hours time
frame I'll enter a short towards the
range lows and then thisa into our long
here to go back up pretty simple okay uh
just be careful because in this one here
is where you get stopped out because uh
I mean this this triangle can go for
ages go to the 4 hours time frame I've
seen this on Twitter it's happening to a
lot of people okay you can draw this
this is how people were drawing
yesterday
okay yesterday people were drawing I
think it was something like this and
Traders were basically opening Longs in
this candle here this is small green
candle let me know if you can see it
okay because as you can see it's
testing the the top of this triangle a
support and then people are expecting
price to go up but it doesn't it gets
back inside that the pant okay then
people open short that's what Traders do
okay Traders open short again because
maybe breaks to the downside now that
was the fake out drop to the downside
again price pushes back up to the entry
they get stop again so you can see how
the retail Trader gets stopped out so
careful okay now
probably I mean how do you even
interpret this do you keep the the top
line of yesterday and you saying okay
it's a test of support or what you can
do is uh the triangle is not done okay
you just readjusted and you're still
inside the triangle
so it's not uh Penance is not something
that I include in my trading system it's
not something that I uh that I
particularly like I think it's useful to
to see what the retail Trader is
thinking because most Traders trade like
this and manipulation is not cor where
the ret trade is straight because that's
what the market maker cares about okay
what the money is so uh be careful with
this okay because it wouldn't be
unuseful if we see a fake out here and
drop or even a drop a straight away okay
and then you know GG there is nothing
there is nothing to to look out for here
okay so uh careful with that guys I'm
not going to go through the liquidation
hit maps and neither through the order
book because I've already checked and
it's pretty much the same as yesterday
so I cannot give you any more insight or
information about it um so we're going
to do that okay just with a chart um
Also let's go to
ethereum very quickly okay ethereum is
pretty much again at the range highs
you can see it okay ethereum is only 1
to 44% away from the range highs Bitcoin
let me
see Bitcoin
is pretty much well more than the double
3 to 50% okay so why not why couldn't
Bitcoin go to the range highs again
before dropping okay is Bitcoin going to
go again to the range SI then of course
we'll see that if it gets tested a
resistance and with drop and that'll be
the fake out that I'm telling you about
a pennant okay or if it goes above this
resistant then hold it a support and
then that should continuation towards
that week okay so um why not if ethereum
has gone to the range highs pretty much
why is Bitcoin going to do the same
right now if we see this drop that we're
talking about to the range lows that's
going to give us some good entries not
only in Bitcoin but in some altcoins we
can go to for example link
we go to link um what I see here is that
we have the 4H hour 50 ma very close to
the to the price uh price is pretty much
doing some kind of sideways uh
consolidation so um if we see the drop
in Bitcoin it's quite likely that link
also drops towards the 4our 50a which is
also you can see a a previous support
here okay that could consolidate that
support and maybe from here you can see
see um another um leg up towards this
resistance again okay maybe you have
here some kind of a range okay
consolidation and then you'll see what
happens um that's another entry that I'm
looking at and is that if Bitcoin drops
link should follow okay go towards this
uh 50 ma also that support okay if it
holds you go yourself a good entry PKA
do let's go to dot the same okay you
have here a liquidity pool that could be
a good entry okay so if you do this why
couldn't this be some kind of a w
formation okay retrace that liquidity
pool and then have some continuation
okay again what you see here all of this
that you see here is nothing but
sideways this is consolidation okay this
is not an uptrend it's not downtrend
neither it's consolidation okay after I
move up nothing else so um of course
yeah if Bitcoin drops then PKA do is
going to also follow it'll go towards
this liquidity pool it could even go low
of course and go back to this to these
lows and maybe we can look up for the W
formation okay um so that's pretty much
everything that I'm that I want to say
in this video guys thank you so much for
watching and I'll see you soon